okay today I'm going to talk to you
about desalination so if a solution is
said to be saline it means it's salty
so what desalination means it's just
removing salt from water so we might
want to do this in order to create
drinking water so there's two main ways
that we need to know about in terms of
desalination one is thermal desalination
and the other one is by a process we're
going to learn about in a minute called
reverse osmosis so first of all thermal
desalination whenever we see the word
thermal in science we're thinking about
heat so the way that this works is a
processor might have come across in
chemistry called distillation so we
start off here with a mixture of salt
and water a saline solution remember the
whole thing that we're trying to achieve
is we're trying to remove the salt and
create drinking water clean water so
what we can do is we can actually heat
up this salty water in a lab you get it
with a Bunsen burner but in an industry
might do it in a big big boiler or
furnace but you actually by heating the
water you cause this water here to
evaporate so by evaporating it the salt
does not evaporate and it stays here but
the water does evaporate so it passes
down here so turned it to it from a
liquid to a gas and turns down here now
in the condenser what happens is the
steam actually condenses so remember
this term means turning from a gas back
into a liquid so we've so the water can
then drip down here so what we've done
is we've evaporated the water leaving
the salt behind then the steam because
this condensed is really nice and cool
it condenses and turns back from a gas
into a liquid and goes in here
this is now clean drinking water that we
can save the drink okay
the next process we're gonna look at is
reverse osmosis so hopefully we already
know a little bit about osmosis
so as Moses remember is the movement of
water particles from a high
concentration to a low concentration
across a partially permeable membrane so
I'm just going to draw the set up right
here
so the blue circles here what they
represent these are water molecules so
I've got two sides of my membrane one I
have a high concentration of water
molecules and the other one I have a
high / lower concentration of water
molecules because these represent these
green circles represents salt molecules
so again remember desalination means
removing salt from the water I want to
end up with just water and remove my
salt now in normal osmosis the higher
concentration of water is on this side
so in normal osmosis we have a net
movement from here to here from a high
concentration of water to a low
concentration of water across a
partially permeable membrane but in
reverse osmosis as the name suggests
it's the other way now the reason why
water moves the other way is a lot of
pressure is applied from this side right
here so there's pressure put on this
side right here now this causes instead
of in normal osmosis where we go from a
high concentration of water to a low
concentration of water we actually go
the other way so the water molecules
actually move this way now the reason
why the salt does not cross and go that
way is because the salt is too big to go
through our partially permeable membrane
that's what partially permeable means it
means it only lets certain things
through so in this case the water
molecules move from this side to this
side so the salt the stuff we don't want
is left behind and on this side all of
this water can be taken off
and removed for drinking water so just
to summarize desalination means removing
salt from water we could do this by
thermal desalination by evaporating the
water and condensing it again to
separate it from the salt or by reverse
osmosis where we apply pressure which
causes the water molecules to move
against the concentration gradient from
a low concentration of water to a high
concentration of water to create clean
drinking water thank you